why you shouldn't get married as a Young
Man guys you hit your Peak later in life
than women a man's Peak is from the age
of like 28 to 35 the longer you wait the
higher quality of a girl you can attract
once you have your business established
when you're making more money when
you're towards your Peak you're going to
be able to pull a way hotter girl than
at a super young age waiting is not a
bad thing this will make sure you're
happier later on in life and you can
pull a way hotter girl that is not true
because merely pulling a hotter girl is
not a particular really strong predictor
of Happiness later in life and depending
on how much younger she is and how much
hotter she is and what her background is
um it might be quite the opposite is it
okay to date a guy for money yeah he's
right that men are more established and
probably more attractive to women
starting around their late 20s into
their early 30s that that's true but
what are some better predictors